>> MY JEANS TELL ME I'M A MAN.
>> MY JEANS TELL ME I'M A WOMAN.
>> THEY TELL ME I'M RELAXED.
>> THAT I'M A SKINNY?
>> A CHILD.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW ME, JEANS.
>> I'M NOT A STYLE.
>> THAT'S NOT ME.
>> I AM NOT A CHILD.
>> I'M ME.
>> I'M UNIQUE.
>> I'M WOKE.
>> WOKE.
>> SO WHY AREN'T MY JEANS?
>> NOW THEY ARE.
INTRODUCING, STYLE NEUTRAL
GENDER NON-CONFORMING DENIM FOR
A GENERATION THAT DESPISES
LABELS.
LEVI HAS HEARD THAT IF YOU'RE
NOT WOKE, IT'S BAD.
SO WE MADE THESE.
>> DEFINING SOMEONE BY THEIR
STYLE, THAT'S
SENSELESS.
THAT'S WHY LEVI WOKES HAVE NO
STYLE.
>> WHAT'S MY SIZE?
WHY DON'T YOU TRY ASKING ME
ABOUT MY ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
>> MY WOKES ARE SIZE ME.
>> THEY FIT EVERYBODY.
>> BECAUSE THEY FIT NOBODY.
>> WHAT COLORS DO THEY COME IN?
>> COLORS?
>> I'M TRIGGER.
>> THIS COLOR.
CAN YOU LABEL THIS COLOR?
>> THAT IS THE COLOR GREB.
>> THEY NOT BROWN, BUT THEY NOT
NOT BROWN.
>> IT'S A HANDFUL OF COLORS.
NONE OF WHICH ARE DOMINANT.
>> JUST LIKE OUR COUNTRY.
>> OH, WAIT.
>> WOKE!
>> LET'S TALK POCKETS.
POCKETS SOLD SEPARATELY.
>> YO, WHO SAYS I HAVE HANDS?
ARE YOU GETTING THIS YET?
THE JEANS ARE WOKE.
>> WOKE.
>> DO THEY COME IN MEN'S AND
WOMEN'S.
>> NAH.
>> DO THEY COME IN PERSON?
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
THAT'S WHY WOKE'S GOT A UNI FLY.
>> 180 DEGREES OF GENDER
NON-CONFORMITY.
>> MY JEANS HAVE WOKE STYLE.
DO YOURS?
>> WHAT DON'T YOU GET?
THEY WOKE.
>> WOKE.
>> GET WOKE.
>> WE'RE WOKE.
>> YOU, HOLD UP.
>> ARE MY WOKE'S MADE IN SOME
FACTORY BY INDONESIAN KIDS?
NAH, THEY MADE RIGHT HERE IN THE
U.S.A. BY WHITE KIDS.
>> WAKE UP WITH LEVI WOKES.
>> WOKE.
>> LEVI WOKE, AVAILABLE
EXCLUSIVELY AT ROSS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪♪♪